[موسيقى]
علاقه العرب بالنجوم علاقته ازليه فهي من
صميم ارثهم وثقافتهم فهم الذين اسموها وما
زالت شعوب الارض تنطقها كما نطقها العرب
وعن طريقها يعرفون مواقعهم ومواسمهم
وعلامات وبالنجم هم يهتدون وقسموا النجوم
الى قسمين نجوم استدلاليه ونجوم حسابيه
اهم الحسابيه الثريا واهم النجوم
الاستدلاليه الجدي والطبع ما ينزال غيره
بتبديل مثل الجدي مرساه ليله ونهاره
والحنظله له على شاطئ النيل زادت مرارتها
القديمه مراره
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فشروق وغروب الثريا وتوسطها عنان السماء
لها دلائل حسابيه عندهم فشروقها مع شروق
شمس شرقا دليل على بدايه الحر اللي هي
مربعانيه الجيل وتوسطها عنان السماء مع
شروق الشمس دليل على شده الحر اللي هي
جمره
وغيابها مع شروق الشمس غربا دليل على
نهايه الحر وهو موعد لقائها مع الليل واني
لاهون النوم في غير حينه لعل لقاء في
المنام يكون تحدثني الاحلام اني اراكم فيا
ليت احلام المنامي
يقين
[موسيقى]